and thanksgiving is just six days away
and health officials are urging people
not to travel this year
many are listening to top officials and
staying home the red cross has put
together some tips to help everyone
enjoy that holiday safely
eight news now reporter madison
kimbrough joins us live now with the
details in madison you spoke to some
people about their holiday plans
yes i did and fortunately everyone was
in agreeance that they were going to
stay home
this holiday the red cross made a list
they put a list together reminding
people that small gatherings
are the safest option when celebrating
with family
also one major part of the holiday
season is sharing recipes
and dishes now that still can be done
just make sure to deliver them
without direct contact we spoke to some
people
at welcome to las vegas sign to hear how
they are celebrating
we had a family coming up from arizona
but because of kova they're not going to
come up so we're just going to keep it
small just the two of us
i'll be doing to the holidays like every
person would do just staying home
my mother recently passed she passed
away from
pneumonia kovid about three months ago
so it's just me my brothers and
my my father
and the red cross also mentioned that
kitchen safety is something you always
have to be cautious of
and conscious of when cooking a lot of
food use a timer to remind yourself
that the stove or oven is on a fire is
the last thing you need during this time
now a reminder to los vegas governor
sislex mandate
the stay at home 2.0 mandate there's
three days left so we don't know as of
now what new restrictions could be put
in place but of course
we'll keep you updated reporting live
madison kimbrough 8 news now